today's San Francisco could become the
first city in the country to ban the use
of facial recognition technology local
lawmakers will vote on a bill that would
prohibit the use of the technology in
all city departments that includes
police body cameras Jonathan Vigliotti
shows us the growing concern about
privacy and racial bias it's at the
airport and in our cell phones the
convenience of facial recognition
technology is part of our everyday lives
and it's also being used to catch
criminals so this is how it works a
person suspected of committing a crime
is caught on a surveillance camera like
this one a screen grab of the person's
face in this case may is then uploaded
to this database containing hundreds of
thousands of mug shots of people with
previous arrests it saves us time it
helps us be more efficient it helps us
be more cost effective officers at the
Washington County Sheriff's Office just
outside Portland Oregon have been using
Amazon's recognition software for nearly
two years
senior systems analyst Chris head Zima
says the software works a lot faster
than the human eye the chin eyes
everything is measured so the computer
is at literally looking at the face it's
looking at measurements on a race and
comparing it to other measurements on
source photos yes the efficiency and
convenience has critics asking if the
possibility of being tracked and
identified is worth the risk
cities like San Francisco Oakland and
Somerville Massachusetts are about to
answer that question they could be among
the first to ban the technology at all
government agencies facial recognition
is biased against people of color and
it's often inaccurate for proof
lawmakers and civil liberty watchdogs
point to the ACL u--'s test of Amazon's
facial recognition program after
scanning images of members of Congress
and then comparing them to archived
arrest photos 28 lawmakers were
incorrectly matched
including six members of the
Congressional Black Caucus facial
recognition in the hands of police
departments will fan the flames of
discriminatory policing it will result
in more dangerous encounters between
members of the public and the police
it's not like hey it comes up and then
that's my guy and we go put handcuffs on
somebody and take them to jail it
doesn't work like that at all
detective mark Pavoni says in the right
hands that technology can be useful we
need to use it responsibly it's there is
room for you no error there and abuse
and so that's why we have very specific
policies at limit how we can use it in
why and when all right thank you very
much facial technology is something that
everybody's looking at but they still
seemingly have a lot of kinks that they
need to work out well it's time
identifying people of color I've heard
and San Francisco can choose to do what
it wants to do and other communities can
make their choices and then you know if
it works out they'll change their mind
it's a perfect experiment for local at
the local level all right